[Applause]
dear viewers Venezuela may soon undergo
a historic change
Astaire's momento Luciana
blow de Venezuela for first time it
feels like we're on the verge of
witnessing the ends of Chavez's
Bolivarian revolution as you all know
this man Juan cuido the president of the
Venezuelan National Assembly has been
proclaimed interim president of the
country and over 50 world leaders along
with almost all Latin American countries
have already recognized him as such it's
last week Canada joined many of its
allies and recognized Juan Pardo
as the interim president of Venezuela el
gobierno de espana a nausea Karagounis a
official meant a our senior y la
marquise como president encargado
develop alum BIA reckon on saying ah
Hwang white Oh
como Presidente de Venezuela 1y though
como president in Kargil Parliament
Oviedo two weeks ago the United States
officially recognized the legitimate
government of Venezuela and its new
press
one
[Music]
all this coupled with the United States
as recent sanctions which are frozen all
revenues have put the Bolivarian regime
in a very tight spot we're going to
announce sanctions against petróleos de
Venezuela Sociedad aneema or paid of asa
as it's known by its Spanish acronym the
state-owned oil monopoly give you the
scenario that Nicolas Madeira now faces
is complicated really complicated for
one thing not only has his Authority
been questioned in the global arena
opposition from the Venezuelan
population it's also undeniable secondly
the country is on the verge of
collapsing as a whole because it's about
to run out of dollars and petrol yep
petrol you've heard that correctly
Ivan's all now Venezuela has been
importing a significant chunk of its
petrol from the United States check this
out
[Music]
the EVs a imports 70% of the gasoline
the domestic market consumes but of
course now a virtually worthless
Venezuelan currency has no ability to
buy dollars those days they're simply
over so now the question remains can a
country survive without petrol and
without oil and the answer is I doubt it
and you know what Nicolas Maduro and his
henchmen they know this and they know
that the time might be about to run out
forever but let's consider what that
would mean for just a minute more
specifically let's look at these two
questions number one how has this Avista
regime now headed by Nicolas Maduro
survived for so long and two is a
peaceful transition possible folks the
answer to both of those questions
involves the same characters so listen
up
[Music]
the Bolivarian Gestapo now let's not
fool ourselves changing Venezuela is
going to be a very very difficult task
and this is even the case if Maduro was
to leave quietly the Bolivarian
revolution is not only plundered and
destroyed the Venezuelan economy it has
also created lots of networks and
various interests of all kinds some of
these networks have played a key role in
allowing Maduro to remain in power we're
talking mainly about two institutions
which have been essential for the
maintenance of the entire Chevy ster
regime the first is the regime's
formidable secret police the seven or
Bolivarian National Intelligence Service
the other is phase the Special
Operations force we're talking about
organizations that haven't hesitated to
kidnap imprison robbed repress and
eliminate political opponents and anyone
whom the Chevys - regime considers a
threat
these two organizations have become
maduras army of personal bodyguards and
even if there is a change of government
in Venezuela they would probably
continue operating in the shadows
dedicating themselves to their fields of
expertise robbery extortion and drug
trafficking how did it get to this point
how do these organizations work what
roles are they really play while all of
this it deserves a closer look but first
things first we do have to acknowledge
that this isn't new at all almost all
dictatorships have been known to use
armed forces to consolidate their power
instill fear of speaking out against the
government and of course to get rid of
their political opponents
throughout the 20th century perhaps the
three most well-known cases were
Mussolini's OVR 8 an organization that
kept an eye on and actively repressed
anti-fascism Stalin's people's
commissariat for internal affairs and of
course the Nazis is stopped Oh
the chief goal of these organizations
was not so much about maintaining
security upholding justice but about
consolidating power for their respective
dictatorial governments
well Venezuela's case isn't any
different seven and phase aim to protect
characters such as da da da caballo
narcotraffic Cantona persona
you're a mental effort too much
attention okay no CC was a mess a mess
at the mean and cursor I'm going to our
parade my photo and folks as the
economic crisis grows these two armed
groups have been stepping up their
activity we need to look no further than
January 2019
after want we declare a Shahnaz
president and the subsequent public
protests calling from the Duras stepped
down Madero use these organizations to
try and silence the protesters and
here's a question for you can he guess
how they went about it it's not so
difficult because it's straight out of
the dictatorship playbook in the first
week after Guido's Proclamation is
estimated 35 people were dispatched
falling victim to these criminals and
more than 800 others were arrested
[Music]
the revolutions dirty war back in 2015
Midori created the PLO the operation of
the People's Liberation with the
supposed objective of combating the
growing violence that the country was
experiencing there was a move that would
have horrendous results for Venezuelans
you see between 2015 and 2016 it's
estimated that there were around
eighteen thousand cases of arbitrary
arrests searches without a warrant and
even executions building on this
experience that regime went on to create
the phase or special action forces in
2017 this was an intervention group with
special training and very particular
procedures check this out
first they use military force to take an
area as if they were an occupying army
then they proceeded to hunt their
objectives
this isn't about citizen security or an
offender's actions are prevented or he's
arrested within a legal framework no in
their case they understand that they
have to get rid of elements who aren't
so much people as enemies of the regime
kar Avila the fa es work in popular
neighborhoods with officers dressed in
black and equipped with sophisticated
combat equipment will say if you Cynthia
Roundhill former vice president of the
Republic and former defense minister
[Music]
so you could say the phase uses
brutality and beer as their default
techniques and not only do they carry
out random acts of extreme violence
they've also become in many cases
veritable criminal groups that have
turned theft organized crime and
extortion into sources of income and to
top it off they act hands in hands with
the so called collectives these are para
police groups with many local volunteers
amongst their rank and they were created
armed and financed by the Shiv Easter
regime they were first formed back in
2002 with the idea of controlling
neighborhoods at the grassroots level
that way any Venezuelan who disagreed
with the regime would not only be
controlled by the police and the
intelligence services but also by some
of their very own neighbors controlled
of course terrified because folks in
many cases these collectives have taken
the law into their own hands and have
set up their own businesses which are
also linked to drug trafficking and
extortion in return face often sets up
its operatives within these collectives
and their local businesses so can you
think of another country where police
act hand in hands with criminal gangs
well let me help you out
think about Nicaragua and wouldn't you
know it well they're one of murderers
allies meanwhile 7li powerful Bolivarian
National Intelligence Service created by
Hugo Chavez in 2010 has not been left
out Venezuela tiempo mundo de amigos oh
cool dos de gente que si mula utilizes
la libertad pública para cambiar contra
la paz la tranquila da de la república
Elsa Venus Eun incremental dinero para
no police are no the agents of seven a
symbol of repression in Venezuela are in
charge of the most delicate operations
such as arresting and persecuting
opponents even if these opponents
deputies of the National Assembly or
members of the Venezuelan Parliament
sebin has become one of the symbols of
state terrorism implanted in Venezuela
it's an organization that has developed
a policy of grave human rights
violations Martina Alvarado to this day
both groups operate from the shadows and
with total impunity for example no one
really knows exactly how many agents
work at 7:00 nor how many people have
actually been detained or indeed who is
in charge of the various departments the
only thing we know for sure is that 7 is
ruled by this man Manuel Christopher
Figueroa who is rumored to be under the
thumb of Tareq al Asami high-ranking
minister in maduras government and vice
presidents of the Economic Area a guy
who incidentally is considered a drug
trafficker by the United States we also
know that 7 operates with such impunity
that it even ignores the Bolivarian
courts themselves yep so let me explain
[Music]
there are numerous cases where political
prisoners were ordered to be released by
the Bolivarian justice system but they
are still in jail because seven simply
refuses to let them go so do view the
building that you see here is perhaps
the best proof of the real disaster the
Venezuela has suffered through in the
last few decades let me explain this
futuristic looking building that evokes
the Tower of Babel is the hello Coit a
construction began in 1956 and it was
intended to house a shopping center and
a luxury hotel these days it's one of
sevens
two main headquarters this is where they
have their holding cells cells which as
you can imagine are maintained
dreadfully the cells have no bathrooms
you aren't guaranteed medical attention
prisoners are almost always locked up it
could take weeks or months to be let out
for a few minutes I'll never forget that
the inspector who received me after my
arrest told me welcome to hell Viveca
fed an envious former candidate for the
National Assembly once locked up seven
agents charged the families of the
inmates for necessary items such as food
of course that money it goes directly
into the agents own pockets but let's
get back to the subject at hand do you
know the extent of what these groups
have done in recent years
[Music]
well according to information provided
by the Organization of American States
we could be talking about in excess of
8,000 executions mainly carried out by
these groups and that's only since 2015
and the data from the Venezuelan
violence Observatory is even worse
according to this organization in 2018
alone security forces got rid of more
than 7500 people folks said in a phase
they not only have been nicolas maduro
x' armed wing they also have been the
life support that's kept him in power if
the time for change does come then no
doubt going to cause quite a few
headaches if these groups already have
links with drug traffickers today it
wouldn't be at all unusual for this to
become their main activity at a later
date but that's something we're going to
talk about in another video now it's
your turn and here's a key question for
you in the interests of moving forward
do you think amnesty should be given to
the leaders involved in crimes such as
kidnapping plundering and destroying
Venezuela well leave your answer in the
comments below as well as in this survey
and I really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos also don't forget to
check out our friends at the reconsider
Media podcast who provided the vocals in
this episode though I not mine also this
channel it's possible because of patreon
and our patrons on that platform please
consider joining them and supporting our
mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see you next time
[Music]